But wait, I don't understand. Let's take the
girl with the heart condition. Neither one of her
parents have the same condition. So how can they
be responsible if they don't share the same trait?
>> Well, one of the big discoveries that I picked up on is that
living organisms have 2 copies of every
gene. And though these copies can be different
from each other. Only one manifests itself as a trait in a certain generation.
Let's use our deck of playing cards as an example. Let's imagine that each pair
has 2 playing cards each. A six of
hearts which correlates with a normal functioning heart, and
an ace which can cause the abnormal heart condition.
Even though one of the copies in the pair
causes the heart condition It's hidden, as long
as the other copy has normal function. So the
parent appears to have normal heart function, even though
they have one normal copy, and one abnormal copy.
When the parents have a child, each parent randomly
passes on one of the cards. As long as
the child ends up with at least one number
card She'll have normal heart function, but if she
ends up with two aces she'll suffer from that
abnormal heart condition. So see if you can figure
out how many total possible combinations there are if
these two parents have a child. And how many combinations
would result in the heart condition.